- [Man] This is salted butter though.
- Mmhmm, this was fun.
This was fun.
- Fried food is disgusting.
It makes me feel gross.
It slows me down.
- You don't feel good
when you eat crappy food.
- I'm nervous.
- I'm excited.
I don't know if my stomach's gonna agree.
- [Woman] It's funny that
we find this appetizing,
like, at all.
- I have no idea what that is.
- Yeah, that's a strange shape.
This is a strange shape.
- I'm pretty unhappy
about being in this video.
- Yeah.
- Alright, this is fried pizza.
- I thought you didn't eat cheese.
- I mean, dude, I don't eat fried food,
like this whole video is like a disaster.
- It tastes like pizza
but it looks like chicken.
- Man
- It's a lot of bread.
- Yeah.
- It's like if you ordered a pizza
and got bread as a topping.
- Yeah.
- You have to like get
past the oily crunch but
this is good
- I like it.
If Italian food were
mixed with American food,
fried, and they had a happy
baby, I think it would be this.
- I was hoping that it was
peanut butter and jelly.
I love peanut butter and jelly by itself.
- Okay, this one I'm nervous about.
- It's like Fear Factor.
Alright.
Damn.
- It's pretty good.
- I can hang with this 24/7.
This is like American french toast.
- Who came up with this idea?
I wanna find out.
We should get this patented.
No, I'm serious.
- It tastes better 'cause it's fried.
- A little bit.
- I do feel a little
bit of a sweat forming.
- This is what the fair is.
Like, they fry everything.
You could probably fry your cousin
if you wanted to at the fair.
- Oh, this is harder to pull apart.
There we go.
Look at that.
- That looks unpleasant.
- Yeah, I'll work with this.
- This one's good.
- This works better because
it's just like owning the fact
that this is terrible.
It's not like mixing weird food.
It's just like junk food upon junk food.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay, I'm done with that one, though.
- It's literally a stick of butter.
(laughs)
- Why you making me eat a fried butter?
People don't do that, alright?
People do that?
- Oh, God, this is so greasy.
- [Both] One, two...
- Nope, nope, nope, nope.
- Yep.
That means Casey James is not gonna be
tasting this thing, guys.
- I think my mind is playing tricks on me.
It tastes like a sugar cookie
but I know it's full butter
and I know my heart's
slowing down because of it.
- It tastes like a waffle.
- Yeah.
- Syrup would be good with this.
- Oh!
- Is it bad?
It's bad.
- Is it that bad?
- I'm like gagging for you.
- Oh, wow, YOLO.
That's pretty horrible.
- I kind of don't mind it.
- Yeah, I'm fighting the strong urge
to take a nap right now.
- I just hope that people don't eat
fried butter on the regular.
- That makes me sad.
- Yeah.
- The butter is gonna
keep me eating healthy
for the next week or so at least,
just to make up for that.
- Yeah, my views has not
changed for this video at all.
Now I just have to do a
couple of, do some running
to get all this crap out of my system.
- I mean, don't get me
wrong, I'm very adventurous,
but a stick of butter's a little too much.
Just a little too much.
- I definitely still feel my
convictions against fried food.
I'm not gonna give in but it
was nice to taste it again.
- I've never just ate butter before,
but so like fried butter,
was just the next step,
but it was so unnecessary in my life.